I would Laura tasks I would love to hear
you do a lecture series on raising
children properly is that something you
would consider well in my new book I've
written a chapter on that called don't
let your children do anything that makes
you dislike them and I've laid out a
bunch of I've laid out a philosophy of
care and discipline that's predicated
partly on a French philosophical legal
notion which is do not multiply rules
beyond necessity it's sort of like a
legal equivalent talking sir a sir and
an English common law principle is which
is use minimal necessary force and I
think the union of those two which is
don't have too many rules but make sure
that you properly enforce the ones that
you do have is a good start for how you
might consider your attitude with
regards to raising children the other
thing you have to figure out is exactly
what's your aim and you know one of the
aims that people have had most recently
pushed by clueless psychologists I would
say is that you want children to have
high self esteem and that's actually a
large part trait neuroticism anyways but
and it can be modified to some degree
Jerome Kagan has done some very
interesting work on that but the best
thing to do I think the best thing to
orient yourself towards with regards to
children is that you're trying to make
your child your children or help your
children to be delightful in the eyes of
others and so that means they have to be
reasonably well socialized and that
really takes place between the ages of 2
& 4 because what you want for your
children is that when they go out into
public when they're away from you or
even with you for that matter
what you want for your children is for
other people to genuinely like them
because if they behave reasonably and
they attend properly to adults and they
know how to play with other children
then wherever they go
they're going to be unless they
encounter someone truly malevolent
they're going to be welcomed with smiles
and open arms and that's not going to be
fake because
almost every human being actually likes
children if they're reasonably behaved
and so your job is to make your children
highly socially desirable because that
opens up the world to them so there
that's not a lecture series but it's a
little lecture